hey guys I am extremely excited for this
video if you guys are new here you may
not be familiar with my obsession with
hue lightbulbs their app controlled
lights that you can install in your home
and you can control everything from just
that your phone so years ago I
discovered these and I have been
collecting them ever since and they just
recently came out with this this is the
white ambience kit so it's pretty much
from sunrise to sunset so it kind of
gives you every color of white light
possible so you may be asking yourself
Justine why in the world would I want to
add controlled lights and I'm gonna ask
you why in the world would you not it is
the coolest thing ever so do a quick
little unboxing of the new white
ambience kit so the difference between
this and this is if you want to have
colored lights and you would be getting
one of these ones it's the white in
color ambience but for those of you who
aren't really into having crazy colors
in your house you can get this one which
just came out and for anyone who was
looking to get into this you have to
have a starter kit he has a starter kit
compass oh this is exciting
yeah the white ambience comes with a
light switch which allows you to turn
your light on off and you can also dim
up and dim down this is kind of exciting
so the reasons you need to start with it
is because it comes with this this is
the hue bridge it comes with two light
bulbs it's super easy to set up you
basically plug this in connect the
bridge to your existing router in your
house download the hue app what's the
color starter kit which I currently
already have set up it comes with a
bridge and three light bulbs this is one
of the down lights and this is one of
the regular little tiny light this is
one of my favorites it's the hue LED
light strips so with the new version the
2.0 you're able to add extensions to it
so you can get one of these and then add
extensions and you can have them all
around your house I'm going to put this
one
in my bedroom here's the LED strip
here's cor here's the plug so I just saw
a lot of the white ambience lights right
here and I'm going to show you guys how
easy it is to add lights light setup
search for lights and there it is so you
can set up different rooms which make it
super easy to control different lights
from wherever you are so I'm gonna make
a new room I'm just gonna call it the
test room add the lamp this is where the
fun starts
I can turn it off I can turn it on this
is where I can change all of the
different colors of the white and I can
add different types of recipes four
types of things that I want to do this
is our nice relaxing color this is our
reading color this is our concentrate
color and this is our energized color
you can also choose from pretty much any
color of white on the spectrum that you
want let's switch to the color now as
you get the gist of what the hue lights
are have a little fun by installing some
more lights Jenna you want to help me
install some light bulbs here's a tip
that I would like to give to you guys if
you're installing these high up take a
picture of the serial number on it just
to help in case it won't connect to
Wi-Fi all you have to do is type in the
serial number and hit connect and it'll
usually find it
I love it it's great don't this is
tropical Twilight this is the Savannah
sunset but for us wow so bright
so a few more lights shall we
success oh my gosh I'm so excited this
is incredible so my favorite things
about Hugh is there's tons of other apps
the third parties have developed to work
with the lights a few of my favorites
are Hugh party and right now we're going
to be using Hugh disco so this will
connect to your lights it'll listen to
the music you have playing and it will
adjust the lights accordingly do your
dance
so the dance party's over you have to go
back to work you can hit concentrate so
concentrating is great but what I really
like is a dance party
just doing some light reading before the
party
and now time to bed bedroom let's choose
a nice scene this over here is one of
the go lights and it's probably one of
my favorite hue lights for this very
reason it's like a magical glowing orb
so it's battery-powered and when it's
plugged it in the wall it charges magic
so another cool thing you can do is you
can add routines so you can add a wake
up routine so not only do I usually set
my alarm but I actually set my hue
lights to wake me up so tomorrow I
actually have to get up at 5 a.m. not
excited about it and so you can say what
time you want to wake up so you can see
how long you want it to fade in until
that time and then tomorrow 5:00 a.m. my
lights will wake me up I'm going to hit
my nightlight and go to sleep okay but
I'm not really because I have to hit
stop on the video thank you so much for
watching hope you guys enjoyed this
video now I'm actually gonna go to sleep
bye
I'm good at everything